[Música]
es que las acusaciones penales contra el
expresidente Donald Trump imputado por
cargos penales que implican delitos como
obstrucción a la justicia o violación de
la ley de espionaje marcarán los
próximos meses y la campaña en Estados
Unidos recordemos que Trump es el primer
expresidente acusado por delitos penales
tras previos casos civiles como la
imputación por el caso stormy Daniels
pero Trump no es solo ex mandatario sino
que también es precandidato a la
presidencia para el partido republicano
ahora desde Washington Contamos con
Federico de Jesús él es analista
político y Vamos a abordar con él
gracias a él esta situación Federico
Buenos días para usted muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en France 24
le empiezo planteando
Federico le empiezo planteando
precisamente si es posible que este
juicio tenga lugar antes de las
elecciones de 2024
Sí todos los análisis inclusive los
fiscales cuando anunciaron los cargos
dijeron que querían un juicio rápido la
justicia Verdad que no es a tiempo pues
es justicia negada y por el calendario
político y también por la persona que se
trata debe de ser un juicio Expedito y
todos esperan que que se tarde menos de
un año obviamente pueden haber
apelaciones y eso se puede tardar más
pero este juicio en particular se debe
de tratar mucho menos que eso y
cuéntenos cómo sería si Donald Trump es
hallado culpable y enfrenta el final de
la campaña o incluso una eventual
presidencia desde la prisión
Sí todo es posible yo yo dudo que eso
llegue a ese punto en ese momento porque
de nuevo Yo creo que sí serán encontrado
culpables apelará luego Si lo encuentran
culpable y lo ingresan a la prisión
tienen el problema de que él es
candidato presidencial y que tienen
servicio secreto pero también sigue
siendo un ciudadano como cualquier otro
y Y eso es algo que Estados Unidos nunca
ha enfrentado es verdad no O sea que no
no sabemos es algo simple precedente
Obviamente el expresidente enfrenta a
otros cargos y otros juicios que esto
solamente pica y se extiende en este
momento Esto es lo más grave que que
hemos visto es la primera vez con un
expresidente de Estados Unidos enfrenta
a cargos federales ya él habían roto
récord y es el primer presidente ex
presidente enfrentar ningún tipo de
cargo criminal por el juicio de Nueva
York pero son cargos estatales estos son
los Estados Unidos que él dirigió en
contra de él Hola Federico Buenos días
yo le quería preguntar un poco Cómo está
la situación al interno del partido al
final hemos visto muestras de apoyo
significativas por parte de incluso
contendientes que se van a jugar también
la nominación republicana en los
próximos meses al final Donald Trump es
el candidato mejor postulado para ganar
la nominación y entiendo que es sus
rivales tienen que caminar haciendo
finos equilibrios para no pasarse con
las críticas a Donald Trump dado que si
finalmente gana Trump la nominación pues
van a tener que remar todos a una para
después ganar la presidencia
y también tiene la dinámica que de
algunos que son sus contrincantes
realidad no están lanzándose para la
presidencia sino para hacer los
candidatos a vicepresidentes de Donald
Trump y por eso no se atreven a
criticarlo inclusive vicepresidente que
los seguidores de Trump amenazaron con
con Carlos y ha sido muy tímido en en
criticar a su jefe político es muy
lamentable el ex gobernador de Nueva
Jersey ha sido muy vocal en en sus
críticas pero sus contrincantes por lo
general han sido muy tímidos Y eso es
algo muy serio el partido republicano se
suponía que fue el partido de la
seguridad Nacional
los secretos de la nación y les estar
defendiendo Trump en estas
circunstancias no los hace quedar muy
bien especialmente frente a un
electorado general quizás no el
electorado primarista de los
republicanos pero un electrodo general
en las elecciones del 2024 no ves esto
con ojos positivos Federico precisamente
le quería preguntar por este electorado
republicano en las elecciones de 2024 es
posible que otra causa contra Donald
Trump esta por la que fue imputado ayer
en Miami ya desapegue algunos votantes
del partido republicano de un candidato
tan polémico
Disculpa no te escucho bien la pregunta
sí Federico quiero decir si esta causa
esta nueva causa contra Donald Trump
puede ser un poco la gota que colme el
vaso y que algunos votantes del partido
republicano ya lo vean como un candidato
demasiado polémico para ser de nuevo
Para ocupar de nuevo la Casa Blanca
hay encuestas que dicen que el 64% de
los electores primaristas republicanos
no les afecta estos cargos eso es mucho
pero dejar la puerta abierta a otro
porcentaje más pequeño que sí le afecta
yo creo que cuando empieza a desfilar la
evidencia obviamente esto no va a ser un
juicio televisado Así que también eso va
a dificultar la cobertura mediática va a
ser muy limitado no se van a permitir
cámaras ni siquiera se van a poder
enviar tweets desde el juicio pero yo
espero que cuando salga más evidencia ya
con el piano acusatorio es bastante
dañino pero yo creo que que hay algunos
republicanos que van a tener que ver la
luz porque si no entonces Estados Unidos
se está enfrentando una situación que
nunca ha enfrentado Y eso sería muy
lamentable no solo para Estados Unidos
sino para el partido republicano tenemos
que desde que Trump es presidente en el
2016 los republicanos han perdido todas
las elecciones desde allá para
así que eso pues no No necesariamente
quiere decir que Trump porque es el más
popular sea una receta de éxito a nivel
nacional para ese partido
yo le quería preguntar usted menciona
que según las encuestas el 64% de los
republicanos o potenciales votantes
republicanos sigue
mostrándose a favor de Donald Trump y
que no le afecta todos los procesos
judiciales que el expresidente tiene
bueno en su contra yo le quiero
preguntar entonces
Hacia dónde va esta polarización
política en Estados Unidos vale todo en
Estados Unidos se ha polarizado tanto la
sociedad que cualquier juicio cualquier
procedimiento cualquier escándalo va a
ser legitimado por al menos la mitad del
país
No yo no creo que es la mitad yo diría
que que hay como un venta un 30%
del partido republicano que son
fanáticos de Trump que creen cualquier
cosa que escuchan que si les dicen que
el sistema los está persiguiendo a ellos
le creen nadie está presidiendo Nada
aquí el expresidente fue el que cometió
los agregados crímenes hasta sus propios
abogados se viraron y y van a ser
testigos en su contra eso dice mucho el
expresidente ya ni siquiera pudo tener
sus propios abogados pero sobre tu
pregunta si se vale todo la sociedad
estadounidense está tan polarizada Pues
mira Esto va a ser la prueba de fuego
hemos visto mucha encuestas pero este es
el momento de la verdad aquí es que de
verdad se va a decidir Cómo la sociedad
estadounidense va a atender esto y yo
creo que es un shock necesario Estados
Unidos necesita poder decirle al mundo
eso de todo el mundo es igual ante la
ley es cierto porque otros países han
enjuiciados expresidentes corruptos que
han cometido crímenes y no puede dejar
pasar que un expresidente haga lo mismo
porque sea expresidente no enjuiciarlo
Entonces eso le abre la puerta a otras
personas y al sistema a ataques de
hipocresía que Estados Unidos no se
merece Así es Y ahora mismo la sociedad
está polarizada pero hay que ver al
final de juicio al final de la campaña
Cuál es Estados Unidos emerge y cómo se
va a comportar la sociedad y yo creo que
esta es la prueba vamos a ver si si de
verdad se mueve electorado vamos a ver
si la decencia en Estados Unidos Todavía
queda y y cuánto de esa mayoría está
dispuesto a echar la Constitución y los
valores que tanto han luchado por la
borda si lo van a defender de verdad que
ahora vamos a saber esa pregunta tuya
Federico pues Lamentablemente se nos
acaba el tiempo para continuar abordando
esta cuestión seguro que continuaremos
hablando de los casos contado en altarán
hay investigaciones preliminares por el
intento de manipulación de los
resultados en Georgia por el asalto del
Capitolio seguro que este tema no acaba
aquí ni muchísimo menos Muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros
Gracias
Marta Muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos También en esta entrevista
Y ustedes Recuerden que hacemos una
breve pausa pero que enseguida volvemos
con más